many in federal law enforcement knew
perfectly well there was going to be a
huge demonstration in Washington on the
afternoon of January 6 2021 and that it
could become potentially violent there
is no debate about that fact the FBI
knew but it's also clear that many on
the U.S Capitol Police Force the front
line officers who protect the Congress
did not know they had no idea what was
coming and because they didn't know they
were completely unprepared for what
happened that day that is a very strange
failure of communication and it has
never been explained
to understand more about the response to
January 6th inside the capital we sat
down with a man called tarek Johnson
Johnson served as a Capitol Hill Police
Officer for 22 years on the day of the
protest he says he was responsible for
securing the certification of the
presidential election
if there is anyone at the very heart of
the January 6th story its former Capitol
Police Lieutenant tarek Johnson and yet
for some reason the January 6 committee
never called him to testify my voice was
one of the first ones you hear on the
audio transmission so
um I I did expect to get an interview at
some time but no it didn't happen I
guess the focus on
um was on Donald Trump according to
Johnson no one answered his numerous
pleas for help over Capitol police radio
frequencies Johnson says he quote didn't
hear anything on the radio according to
Johnson Yogananda Pittman kept Vital
Information about the protests from
Frontline officers like him Pitman was
the assistant chief of the department in
charge of intelligence operations we
should have been better prepared that
day and we could have been better
prepared that day if the information was
disseminated like it was supposed to be
once protesters moved inside the
building Johnson's first concern was the
safety of senators his job was to
protect them in Rising Panic he called
over the radio for direction and
assistance even now two years later he
is baffled by the response he got I was
requesting permission to evacuate the
Senate side
um the Senate chambers because I had a
clear line of sight to get them out the
Senate door and I didn't get permission
um the dispatcher called a couple times
to see if I can get permission no
response with yoga Nanda Pittman and his
other supervisors unresponsive Johnson
says he decided to begin the evacuation
of senators himself the person that I
thought was going to authorize the
evacuation didn't do it I wanted to get
those members of Congress out as quickly
as I could that's why I initiated
um you know those evacuations me being
disciplined it wasn't as important as
not getting the members of Congress and
their staff to safety footage we
reviewed seems to bolster Johnson's
account the video shows Johnson
conducting the evacuation of senators
from the chamber yet tarek Johnson was
not rewarded for what he did he was
punished a photo emerged of Johnson
wearing a Maga hat outside the capitol
that picture cost him his career
sometimes I look at it and like thank
you God for blessing me with this hat
and sometimes I'm like
wow I wish this hat never came in my
life a Biden voter Johnson says he
donned the Hat in an effort to rescue
fellow officers he believed were trapped
in the building I figured if I had the
Hat on it'll be easier for me to
navigate my way through the crowd it was
basically self-preservation and
de-escalation
um and I needed to get up those steps I
couldn't say what would have happened
walking through that crowd without it
but for the crime of wearing a trump hat
Johnson found himself suspended
ultimately he resigned from the force
and lost his pension he now works
part-time as a Furniture mover Yogananda
Pittman meanwhile thrived two days after
January 6 Nancy Pelosi elevated Pittman
to acting chief of the Capitol Police
late last year Pittman took a
high-paying job as the head of security
at UC Berkeley which is right outside
Pelosi's congressional district
Berkeley announced Pittman's hiring with
unqualified praise for her quote
steadfast commitment to social justice
Pittman herself boasted about her heroic
performance on January 6th her
Department she said quote saved
democracy that day
we reached out to Yogananda Pittman for
comment but she didn't get back to us
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight